once upon a time there was a boy who was
born into a family of simple tailors in
the middle of sub-Saharan Africa the
boy's father wanted him to continue the
family business but the boy wanted a
better life and one night decided to
leave his home and go to Europe
to cross the sea the boy built himself a
raft but once he left the shore there
was only a little wind and it didn't
take long for his supplies to run out
and there he was hungry and lonely
floating in the middle of the
Mediterranean Sea
imagine you live on the coast of
southern Europe and one morning read
about the voice fate in a local paper
should you yourself try to save him
four influential philosophers Aristotle
Mill Kant and Nietzsche can help us
answer this and other difficult moral
questions with their respective theories
virtue theorists like Aristotle ask how
to live a good life the best life
according to him is the life of someone
who demonstrates excellence in aspects
of a virtuous character the capacities
for emotion theoretical ideas and
practical wisdom
Aristotle would argue that if helping
the boy is a manifestation of a
personality that's virtuous then you
should save him because being a person
of good character is what matters what
that exactly means differs for every one
of us
if you are rich and Powerful saving the
boy could be easy it might still be the
right thing to do but it doesn't reveal
much of your personality and hence isn't
particularly virtuous
if you have little to no means your
decision to save the boy is much harder
if you still try to do so then this
truly reveals character is virtuous and
is something you should probably try
doing
utilitarians such as Jon Stewart Mill
ask which action increases well-being
for most people
so when faced with a choice they do what
seems most beneficial to most people as
if they could calculate what
consequences lead to the highest net
happiness
when thinking about saving the boy's
life you should consider all the
happiness the boy and his family get the
joy it may bring you and the benefits
for society now and for generations to
come this you then compare with what
else you could be doing known as your
opportunity costs
for example instead of risking your life
at Sea you could work the day in a
coffee shop and donate the money you
make to an effective charity which then
saves two kids from starvation somewhere
else
comparing the two options you decide not
to save the boy but instead work donate
and double the total potential
well-being of humanity some call this
effective altruism
deontologists like Emmanuel Kant focus
on the intent rather than consequences
they believe in Universal moral laws
such as don't lie don't steal don't
cheat the golden rule is the so-called
categorical imperative our decisions are
then morally right when they can become
a rule everyone else should follow
if you help the boy because it makes you
look good your intentions are wrong
because you treat him as a means to an
end and we don't want to live in a world
in which false heroism is a universal
moral Norm
if you save the boy because you want to
live in a world in which helping those
in need is always the right thing then
you should do that you should even do so
if you have a reason to believe that the
kid may end up taking advantage of your
kindness
Friedrich Nietzsche would ask what's in
your own interest he argued that
self-interested behavior is morally
right as it makes us stronger and if we
are stronger so is society acting
against your own interest is immoral
because it hinders this development
so if you want to help the boy because
you think that is good for you do it
help the boy but if you think saving the
boy could hurt you don't it's not your
responsibility to save those who are too
weak to help themselves
so what do you think did any of the four
help you with that decision if not here
is one more idea
scholar Moshe couple made the
interesting observation that
utilitarians and kantians don't use
their own moral principles when trying
to falsify each other's theories
both rather appeal to a feeling as if we
all inside us actually know what's right
and what's wrong
kantians would say you don't want to
live in a world in which children die in
the open because you decided to save two
strangers instead such Behavior just
doesn't feel right correct
utilitarians would counter surely you
wouldn't want to save say a psychopath
from drowning who then go on to kill you
and your family just because helping
people is always right by principle that
just feels wrong right
so now tell us would you save the boy
and why is your decision based on the
character you strive to become an
analysis of costs and benefits Behavior
we want to see in the world for your own
self-interest or does it maybe just feel
right
share your thoughts in the comments
below
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com
Sprouts just visit us learn how it works
and what's in it for you we hope to see
you there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com